When you're seeing a woman who you're looking to approach,
you know you have the desire to approach her,
but your emotions aren't backing you up and your body's slowing you down.
What it is that you're being stifled in due to impulse control.
So what I do is I call it proof,
not promises.
You want to view your brain as a horse and you have to be good at tricking the
horse into doing what you wanted to do.
Everything that I do on a day to day basis is constantly me tricking my brain.
I trick my brain now I feel an insightful just by maybe doing a little bit of
silly stuff.
It's like a shell that you break out of.
Okay.
I used to do exercises with students.
I don't do this anymore.
I was afraid I'd get in trouble,
but I literally make them take their shirt off and run through the streets
going,
I'm free.
Or like put it on,
put a shirt on like a Ninja Masters Walker.
I'd be like,
God,
like you're like running through the streets.
Some of the best moments of my life.
We're doing that.
It's exhilarating.
I got to tell you,
because what happens is that you'll feel your body going,
no,
like this.
And then because you're doing something so dramatic like running around
shirtless or running out the Ninja mask on your head and had to have like my
boots on my feet and start doing like Ninja poses and shit is completely
bizarre.
It was just social experience.
But it taught me something.
But what happened is I feel like,
no,
no.
And then all of a sudden my brain would go,
he's doing this,
this mother fuckers doing this.
Let's make it better because it's going to do it.
And so it's almost like,
you know,
you're thinking of climbing a mountain and your brain is like,
no,
don't climb the mountain.
Don't lend them out.
Look,
look down.
It looks so scary.
You know,
you look down and get all scared.
But if he just forced her and you start climbing that mountain,
all of a sudden your brain shifts lenses and it's like maybe the climbing the
mountains.
Fun Dude,
that shit down there.
Don't even worry about that.
There's the next rock,
there's the next rock and you start to focus on the upside.
You start to go up.
Your brain actually shifts lenses in terms of what is focusing on.
Here's what my brain led me to do.
It led me to have success barriers.
It led me not to approach women.
It led me to be a coward and led me to be depressed.
It led me to make excuses.
It fucked my life up.
My brain's default pattern is like this,
like garden full of weeds.
I've personally found that my brain will grow weeds and I have to plug the
fucking weeds at times.
I will brow beat myself if I fucked up.
I will sit around and beating myself up for a while and think how I'll change,
but I don't brow beat myself for no reason.
I don't just probably myself like I'm dumb.
I'm dumb,
I'm dumb.
I'll be like,
know what I'm doing right now is fucking perfect.
This is a guy damn joke.
How like change.
What would I change a week ago?
What would I change a month ago?
What would I change to your ago?
And I reflect on that as a man.
I think you have to have a nice like that.
You have to have nice like where you just sit around and think about it.
You know?
Like if I,
if I do something wrong,
sometimes I'll take an afternoon off like three or four hours and I'll sit alone
in a room and I will ruminate on what I did wrong.
That's healthy because that's going to say you got the ship,
it's on autopilot and you spend those couple hours turning the writer to go
somewhere else.
That's healthy.
I have days like that regularly.
If your brain is giving you a hard time,
little do you realize your brands giving you a hard time.
It could mean that by the time that you actually team the damn thing,
it's going to be amazing.
You know?
It could be amazing.
Like I probably have some kind of light autism or or something.
I don't know.
I don't really know.
And what does that mean?
I mean,
people are like,
what?
What does that mean?
Like you're like autism.
Oh my God.
What does that mean?
It means that you think with depth,
not breadth.
That's all it means.
It doesn't mean I'm walking over a toilet go like that.
That's an,
that's a more extreme case in the spectrum on a light case on the spectrum,
you just see things deeply.
You dissect things deeply.
That's in my brain does.
My brain is always going deep all the time.
I'm either present in the moment which case everything's Nice and light or I'm
pulling shit apart.
Thinking of all different directions,
a shit.
Some people would call that bad.
It was bad for me cause I couldn't socialize for 20 years.
But now that I figured out how to work it,
I have an advantage.
I'd like to see somebody who doesn't have a brain like mine,
tried to do what I'm doing and be tough and it'll keep switching on more and
more.
Your intelligence.
If you,
if you keep reading great books,
put healthy shit in your body,
challenge yourself,
put yourself through stress,
try different things.
Your brain will keep switching on more and more and more.
But the last thing I'd say on this topic is look at what I'm doing here,
how it's focused on thriving and not coping.
So you could look at what I'm saying.
It'd be like,
oh,
this is a little much,
just a little heavy.
I mean clearly it's not for everybody,
but what I found was you want to know the best way to get out of your petty
problems,
get better problems,
start thinking bigger,
and then this other shit will seem small.
The problem with a lot of dudes,
they're not thinking very big and if you're not thinking big,
then anxiety over approaching a woman is very real and pervasive and consuming
and that you can tell the size of a man by the size of his problems.
So man,
who's very upset and overwhelmed by a small problem,
it's probably a man was smaller ambitions and a smaller circle of concerns as
Steven Covey would call it.
Because I was walking around in such an angry any state for so many years.
I actually found a lot of relief in thinking it actually paradoxically made my
life easier.
It made my life less pain by thinking bigger because now I'm afraid to approach
that girl.
Huh?
Well,
I've got a lot bigger shit to worry about the most.
Let's go.
So that's what I think is like a thriving as opposed to coping and coping.
Everything seems like a big deal.
Oh,
I'm feeling bad today.
That's another big thing is rapping with,
it's like everything I'm talking to you guys about is about thriving now.
Coping
don't need to do to be happy.
You can be in coping and be happy again.
You're carbon.
Flip your phone,
have a good little wink.
Good can be happy.
But to me it happened to send the bar low.
You know,
people say happiness is the ultimate.
You're making happiness too complicated.
Look your fucking phone.
You'd be happy.
You don't have guys like you.
I just want to get,
you know,
I just want to get a job at subway.
Dude,
how about this?
Stop worrying about the job is subway,
let's by the subway.
Then you can put the fucking little paper had on hire yourself.
You don't,
right.
So it's like you get bigger,
you get bigger,
think bigger,
and then,
and then you're going to a different paradigm.
Like what was it,
Einstein or someone like,
you can't solve the problem in the paradigm of which was created,
go to higher paradigm.
So yeah,
I just,
I love the concept of thriving.
I don't think driving is necessary to be happy.
I think you'd be happy.
I did a lot of people that are,
that are coping through life that are still happy,
but I think you'd be happy anyway,
but then you could thrive just cause just if you want it just to be wanted,
that's it.
No need to,
no need to.